this is a production of Cornell
University let's see if this microphone
works okay Thank You Chelsea I always
tell everyone that I the moment I first
heard of Psych has changed my life and
this is the first time I get to say this
in the room with Chelsea the I first
heard of psych heads in her plant
morphology course at UC Berkeley and she
said at the end of that she was talking
about all the different amazing things
that I'm gonna tell you about about
psych heads and she said if you're more
interested you should go read Island of
the colour-blind by Oliver Sacks and I
literally stopped on the way home at the
UC Berkeley library which did not have
it I have to say so we'll have to check
Cornell um and then stopped at the
Berkeley City Library and got that book
that day and it definitely was a change
in my life I have fallen in love with
psych heads ever since my background is
that I've always been interested in
plant insect interactions particularly
from an agricultural perspective my
background is working a lot in
sustainable agriculture before Chelsie
changed my life so it's okay it's great
I think I hope everybody likes that
Telsey changed my life so I always like
to start with this picture for a number
of reasons I think that right off the
bat I'm used to speaking to really
diverse audiences and so their first
question is what is a psych head so I
like this picture because it tells you a
couple important things about the
biology of the system psych heads are
gymnosperms which I don't have to tell
this room means that they have cones as
their reproductive structures and
they're also dioecious so the female
cones or the ovulate cones are housed on
separate plants and the pollen cones or
the male cones and Here I am looking at
a female plant and looking at all of
these cones but also I love this picture
because it tells a story that matters to
me this was at a field season in Florida
that I went with my husband I have you
can see my wedding ring that was
subsequently stolen when I was mugged in
Brazil the evolution conference and I
think those two things thinking about
relationships and thinking about the
history and the importance of
relationships and thinking about these
plants really come together to like give
a good introduction to what I'm going to
talk about today and really what I talk
about always I think that relationships
are inherently interesting to all of us
and I always say that's evidenced by the
success of every ridiculous romantic
comedy
we ever made no matter how silly the the
storyline or insane the outcome is and
that makes a lot of sense to me because
we're curious we are innately curious
like to answer questions about these
relationships and these are some
examples of movies that I love if none
of you have ever seen this or read the
book this is Lonesome Dove it's an
amazing epic miniseries if you know
anything about me deeply this this movie
sort of and book influences my whole
life I have like a handmade purse of
Lonesome Dove I love this movie so
please all go watch it when you're sick
because it's like six hours long so well
we're quiet we're curious we're curious
about how did we get here and where are
we going how can we help each other how
does this relationship even work and
does someone have to change for this
relationship to work these are things
that were curious about when we're
watching this media depictions of human
relationships but in fact all organisms
engage in a diverse range of
interactions with other organisms
ranging from the obvious predation and
pollination or even or bivy even of
highly toxic plants right to some that
are a little less obvious these are
acacia tree panel obeah more Bocelli
pandemonium and they're ant mutualist
these plants make these DeMeo that the
ants are housed in and in fact on a one
tree will be an entire ant colony that
literally protects them from giraffes
and elephants right this is a mutualism
that we might not know as much about or
this which kind of looks gross two-room
of not insect biologists but these are
butterfly caterpillars butterfly larvae
and they are finge eros is that is the
genus name and their entire life is
dependent on host ants finding them in
the wild on the ground finding them and
taking them into their nest where these
guys parasitize the ant colony by being
fed from the ants so this is a highly
specialized relationship that the the
lineage the evolutionary lineage of this
organism is dependent on a mutualism a
parasitic mutualism and of course
everyone knows this one I'm assuming in
this room with lichen but then I also
put this up this 'santa bacteria but
really just to say that we're getting
more and more knowledge about how
bacteria is important in many ways in
our world from changing behavior and
changing diet
outcomes but if we wanted to ask those
same questions in a biological framework
we might use a little bit more sciency
sounding questions we might ask instead
what is the evolutionary trajectory what
type of symbiosis are we what mechanisms
work to keep us together and has there
been any evolutionary innovation in this
relationship so I study that in psyche
heads specifically because psyche heads
have highly specialized relationships
with both pollinators and
herbivores so these are one-to-one
relationships where the pollinators live
their entire lifecycle on the on the
plant and the plant is dependent on
reproduction on the pollinators I'm
going to talk a lot more about this but
they also have a lot of highly
specialized herbivore relationships
these are you may us at a lab
butterflies that as you can see because
they aggregate they do great damage to
the plant and their entire lifecycle is
dependent on the host plant but I also
study psych heads because they're just
incredible and I had someone reviewing a
paper once not at the review stage but a
collaborator reviewing a paper saying
you should really be careful and not
assume that everyone loves psych heads
which is great if you should all think
about that and writing your papers don't
just assume everyone loves your system
but honestly what is wrong with our
world if you don't love psych heads so
I'm gonna take just a few minutes to
convince you all that psych heads are
incredible plants first off they are
just incredibly beautiful these are
photographs that my husband took at
Montgomery Botanical Center I put these
in not just to show you the beautiful
diversity but also to point out that
psych heads are highly endangered the
most endangered organism are the most
endangered group of plants in the world
most ranged from threatened to
endangered just that louder and
Montgomery Botanical Center is a
conservation garden down in Florida that
grows XE true groupings of these plants
here's just another picture that I love
but also they also demand your attention
in in nature so this is a some field
work I was doing in Panama and just look
at that it's screaming for your
attention right and the attention of
herbivores I should point out but also
there they have an
incredible fossil record extending back
over 265 million years some with this
incredible level of cellular diversity
so they are an ancient plant lineage 265
million years I always feel like I have
to say that a few times to really drive
this home and there's lots of
information that we can learn from this
from their from their fossil record that
hopefully we'll learn more about with
Liz learning a little bit with her but
this is also just kind of interesting to
me because the United States used to
have a fossil National Park a cycad
fossil National Monument it's one of the
very few national monuments in the
history of the US that's ever been
decommissioned and that's because of
theft of the fossils that actually most
of the theft was done by this George
Weiland which is this Yale
paleontologist that really worked to
establish the plants so there's a lot of
fossils of cycads and they're related
and and their related plans so that's
just an interesting side note that I
love but psych heads are also
thermogenic so this this means that they
have their own body temperature they
have their own body temperature a way of
heating up and they do this in their
reproductive structures this is actually
really quite where rare in plants and
when it is found in plants it's usually
that there is either one big burst of
temperature increase or like an increase
in an siRNA maintenance at one level
cycads however have an even more
interesting pattern in my opinion they
increase and heat up in their
temperature over the course of the day
every day for about two weeks when the
plants reproductive it happens in both
the pollen cones and in the ovulate
cones and to a much less degree in the
ovulate cones this is something you
might think of as like an animal trait
body temperature but they also have
another thing that people tend to think
of as an animal trait they have mobile
sperm they have flagellated sperm that
are also gigantic you can literally see
these with the naked eye which is a
really fun thing to do that we should do
in course we're kind of here but just to
prove that they are the end-all be-all
they have an Omega patterning in their
leaf rei'kas and I love this because I
had this really crazy and is probably in
a perfect to say but slightly drunken
night a McGovern Botanical Center where
I was talking to a girlfriend there was
somebody there that is an artist from
New York and she was there doing art
based on sort of botanical
representation in religious ceremonies
and
she and I got all you know a little a
little tipsy together and I was like
dude what if psych heads are God and so
they they're not the Alpha and the Omega
but they certainly have Omega patterning
but they are actually used they have a
lot of religious connotation in
indigenous cultures there's a lot of
anthropology work that goes back and
looks at things for instance that Aztec
maize God the Aztec corn God they
believed is sort of a like a movement
beyond an evolution from a psyche head
worship they believe that psyche had
consumption could have been important
for the Mexican Revolution there's tons
of great information about the history
of psyche heads in that way and they are
still using a lot of religious religious
ceremonies specifically where
Catholicism has taken in some indigenous
religious connotations but something is
a little more important for our story is
that psych heads are super toxic so they
have two classes of toxins I'm just
going to call BMAA and man these toxins
are mutagenic neuro toxic and
carcinogenic and they're they're present
and all cycad Jenner and in all psyche
head tissues and the effects of their
toxicity have been recorded in insects
and animals and even plants which is
amazing if you think about it but that's
a talk for another time and this of
course famous famously has been
discussed in Oliver Sacks his book the
island of the color blind where he
really connected consumption of cycad
toxins with neurodegenerative diseases
of the people of Guam and in fact this
is still a very active area of research
is the toxin BMAA and its connections to
ALS and alzheimer's and parkinson's
disease and so there's a lot of medical
research that's still ongoing they also
have besides their relationship their
specialized relationships with insects
they have other specialized
relationships and this is some of the
stuff that Chelsey first told me about
that blew my mind they have some
specialized morphology to make their
association with cyanobacteria
so they have these colloid roots which
may not be able to see this is a deep
potted plant and here you've got sort of
a caller ID root growing up here's some
if you see in a root ball me holding it
if you cut one of those root nodules
open you'll see a ring of cyanobacteria
this is some ongoing work down at Long
hibiyo and they're really working out
that it's not just cyanide
that's in present in these roots that
there are other bacteria and that the
interactions between those different
bacteria can do different things for the
plants and of course the hypothesis has
always been obviously that Santa
bacteria is fixing nitrogen for cycads
but actually that has not yet been
proven I however am really I think of
myself as a symbiosis biologist and I'm
interested under this umbrella of
symbiosis I'm really a hippie and so I
really think a lot about mutualism but
nothing is just a pure mutualism you may
have a mutualistic relationship with
your partner or your family but trust me
there are some parasitic aspects of that
relationship and so in order to really
understand mutualism you need to also
think about parasitism right and so in
cycads there are very clear distinctions
that allow me to ask those kinds of
questions there's the pollinator
mutualists that i'm going to talk a lot
about today and then i'm gonna i'm gonna
give you some insights that I've gotten
from the parasitic herbivores that that
allow me to understand a little bit more
of the relationship with the pollinators
and what I'm interested in here is
mechanisms I want to understand how does
this work
how is this relationship work so I start
by saying that specialized pollination
is widespread and cycads so for a
long-standing time we thought that
psyche heads were wind pollinated even
even though the presence of insects had
been found on the cones but we now
believe that all psyche heads appeared
to be obligate ly insect pollinated and
in fact it seems to mostly be Coley
after which is the order that includes
beetles and weevils it's found across
the phylogeny and some recent fossil
evidence even dates that - before the
rise of flowering plants so we have a
fossil that shows us where this this
beetle has already evolved morphology
that is specific to its relationship
with psyche heads and living with inside
heads so I study the genus zania which
is neotropical it's we've got one
species native to Florida and then the
rest grow through the Caribbean down
through Central and South America Mexico
and all the way down to Bolivia and I
study this because it's easy cuz it's
here in the US it's much easier
especially because these are endangered
plants and societies regulated and all
that but also because of some great work
done by two different group of
researchers in the 80s studying two
different groups of plants and they were
working on the pollination of those
plants and really challenging the idea
that these are wind pollinated those
researchers
found that they were pollinated by these
genus of weevil row Paulo true weevil
and these were different species of
broke elope cherry weevil they found
also that within a common garden they
were working at Fairchild botanical
Center and / Montgomery botanical Center
or Fairchild botanical garden that the
weevil stayed faithful to their host
plan so one of those groups of
researchers went even further and worked
out the lifecycle of the rope hello tree
weevil and I'll just walk you through it
and then I'll show you some of my own
pictures to give you a little bit more
connection with it so this is a large
male plant with pollen cones all over it
the weevils aggregate on the outside of
a pollen cone at a certain stage of
development of the cone a little bit
before the cone opens then they begin
feeding inside they lay their eggs on it
and on a microscope fill so I'm just
gonna call it a cone scale so they lay
their eggs inside the microspore fill
inside the cone scale the larvae develop
if they develop inside hollowing it out
if one encounters the other you
cannibalizes it and then pupate sin the
stock of the of the cone scale where he
then emerges and does the process all
over again because of their pollination
work we knew that they visited the
female plants they visited the ovulate
cones but they never feed on them they
never aggregate they're in large numbers
they don't lay their eggs on it they
don't develop on there so this was still
an unknown why why do they visit the
female plants and this relationship is
so specialized and important in fact
that the plants only have reproductive
cones for about one and a half to two
months a year so the rest of the ten
months of the year the weebles are in
diapause which you can think of is like
Arrested Development or hibernation
right and think about this this is in
Florida nobody goes to Florida to
hibernate right this is where this is
where people go to retire because it's
comfortable this is where you know girls
none wild spring break stuff happens
nobody is going there to retire but so
for 10 months out of the year these
weevils find Florida - inhospitable for
them
because their life cycle is so tied to
their host plant even when there's a
closely related host plant a meter away
all right so here's some of my own
pictures of that here's a here's a male
plant you can see there's a bunch of
cones it's hard to tell but this cone
here is a lot of weebles all over it
look at them just aggregating like crazy
and
if you break this cone open you'll see a
lot of frass that's weevil poop and
nibble marks here's a weevil covered in
pollen and if you look at a cone and you
open it up you see a little weevil
standing on top of a microscope with the
pollen sacs above them and then here's a
female cone that is cracked open so when
a cone is receptive it goes from being
tightly bound to cracking open to
receive pollen so of course in trying to
understand this connection why do they
leave this house this great home that
gives them everything they need all
their friends are there it's a party
there's food it's like your mom's house
and you're a teenager and then you go
out into the world on your own and you
have to feed yourself right what did
your mom do to kick you out of the house
what how did we get them out of this
house what is this what is this so I
think it has something to do with
communication and I have a little bit of
reason to think that there there are two
other really well-known obligate brood
sight pollination mechanisms which means
that the insect is house and it's and
it's brood develops within the
reproductive tissue of the plant that it
pollinates so the ones that you guys
have all probably heard of are the yucca
and the yucca moth and the fig and the
fig wasp but I'm doing it in something
that doesn't have a flower which i think
is particularly interesting so I think
that has something to do with chemical
communication and that's my hypothesis
and that's why I started working with
and thank God I got lucky because it
meant I got to get a PhD so I started by
asking what is the plant signal this is
communication 101 this is what your
therapist will talk to you about what is
your signal what are you trying to say
how does your partner perceive the
signal and how what is their behavioral
response to the signal that you give
them and does the plant use that to
enact reproduction or does your
communication result in the desired
behavior or the desired outcome that
you're hoping for so I start by asking
what's the plant signal and for this I
do
headspace collection methods so I have
here is a D hissing pollen cone and I'm
taking volatiles from it so I have a
inert plastic bag over it literally a
Reynolds oven bag tied off this filter
here has absorbent material in it and a
vacuum pulling over it so for 45 minutes
I'm pulling the airspace around the cone
over this adsorbent material to get the
smell that the plan is producing the
volatile bouquet which I then aleut and
run on something called gas
chromatography mass spectrometry which
is very simply just a way to separate
all of the ten to fifteen compounds the
plant may be producing so that I can ask
questions about each individual compound
when I do that I find that the plan that
I'm studying is a Mia for Gracie which
is the one that had had all of that
great pollination work done already in
it the plants really produce two main
volatile compounds one that I identified
as 1/3 octave een and one that I
identified as little oh so that's the
plant signal the plant really only has
two channels that it's communicating
through at least of all at least
chemically but that doesn't tell me what
the insect proceeds so insects are
different than humans we can smell
everything right insects have sort of
like a lock-and-key mechanism they have
proteins in their antennae that you
could think of as the lock and the
volatile is the key that it has to come
in and match right to close that lock to
fit into that protein in order for the
insect to perceive it so just the fact
that the plant produces both of these
doesn't tell me what the insect
perceives so for that I do something
called electro antenna graph detection
so this is that GCMs that I talked about
what separates all the volatile
compounds like and asked questions about
each of those and what I'm doing here is
I'm separating those volatile compounds
I'm sending half to be detected and
produce that same image that you just
saw having the peaks at different times
but the other half is coming down this
tube and being bathed to cost this prep
but this is is two electrodes and that's
a weebles little head that I just
chopped off I'm sorry and his head is on
one side and antennae on the other side
and so when the volatile comes and
bathes across that that's the key that
comes into the lock closes the lock and
it closes this electrical circuit and it
creates an electrical charge because I'm
coupling that with the with the other
analyses I'm able to identify which of
those compounds the insect perceives so
this is what that data looks like you've
got that exact same image over top and
on the bottom here's my electrical
charge and then here's the dip dip the
weevil physiologically can perceive 1/3
octave and cannot perceive lynn Lowell
which is a much more common plant
compound but 1/3 octave nyan is not very
common it's found in
and a couple other cycads really in
Africa of all places so this tells me
that the physiological perception and of
course you have to do this many times
and to really identify this you have to
this compound there's many things that
go behind it but you really have to have
a chemist synthesize this standard and
test the weevil against that standard
and I did as the same as little ole and
all the different kiemas of lentil so
we're positive that this weevil
perceives 1/3 octave and nothing else
that the plant produces but that doesn't
tell me what the behavioral responses
that tells me about the insect is
capable of perceiving so for that I did
something called pitfall tests this is
very basic so I've got these petri
dishes with the whole cut in the middle
and a pit in the bottom and in the
bottom I'm putting different
concentrations of 1/3 octave Dean and a
control of course and I put some weevils
in the top close the lid
put in the darks there's no visual
signaling going on and I come back after
30 minutes and see how many weevils have
fallen into the pit telling me is this
an attractant a lot of compounds can be
deterrents for weevils right in fact
that you know this because you you put
different chemicals in to keep you put
chemicals in to keep mice out of the
barn and you put chemicals down to keep
insects out of places right they act
chemicals can be an attractant or a
deterrent so when I do that I see it and
do it a bunch of times right I see that
it isn't attractant this is the number
this is the proportion of weevils that
have gone down into the pit and all of
the different concentrations or amounts
base amounts of 1/3 octave and what you
see is that it isn't attractant here's
nothing in very low amounts it isn't
attractant but it is not linear so you
would think that just if you really like
something it you know the more the more
of it the more attracted you are right
hey Zeus you said you love Donuts is
that right the more donuts the more
attracted you are do you get up to a
point where too much Donuts is
unattractive right so so it tells me it
tells me that this is a track this is an
attractant but not linearly which is
pretty interesting so that made me think
maybe this has something to do with what
causes the movement from the pollen cone
to the ovulate cone and for that I want
to ask can i illicit movement and I
cause insect movement using these two
different concentrations which are
ecologically relevant right these two
different concentrations so with that I
do something where I build these arenas
and so what you've got here is a box
arena with a bunch of weevils in it and
the sides are all mesh so that there is
airflow so there's no like build-up of
volatiles on one side I may put the the
volatile amount on the other side the
1/3 octave Dean amount on the other side
I put a control but nothing to see and
now I'm gonna track these weebles over
time and see if their location changes
do they are they more attractive do they
move towards the lower concentration and
away from the higher concentration this
is what that looks like I just always
think it's such a fun video there goes
so I'm just tracking them over time and
of course some various important things
if a weevil doesn't move at all they're
not counted they may not be dead they
just may be maybe this is the compound
and they're happy they may not be dead
but you can very easily do that using
pixels right understanding that like you
take an average pixel density at this
location throughout the course of the
video and see how it changes right and
when I do that and I'm I'm saying I'm
looking at their change in asymmetry
their change in direction towards the
bait I see that yes at this lower amount
they are attracted they move towards to
the bait at the higher amount they move
away from the bait so what does that
mean though for how plants use that that
weevil behavioral preference for their
volatiles to enact reproduction and I
had some some knowledge right this is
something that I had done in the lab we
know that cones will continue to undergo
at least their thermogenic thermogenic
behavior and even we know that cone
scales are able to continue producing
volatiles and throughout the course of
the day if they're broken off from the
plant so I had taken broken off cone
scales from pollen cones and ovulate
cones 16 of each arranged them in this
arena had it so that air could flow all
of this introduced for weevils into like
a circular arena with a with the pollen
cone scale or an ovule at cone scale in
the center and then I just attract them
all day and said how many are on the
cone scale or within one little
millimeter of it
and you can see from this that there's
definitely they're more attracted to the
pollen cone scale than to the ovulate
comb scale and that there is this big
dip and attraction in the pollen count
scale there is also a statistically
significant dip in the in the female
cone scale but of course this is a lab
setup and so I don't know how much how
much of this dip in either case is
related to the fact that these are
broken off cone scales or what it may
mean right but I do know that I at least
see some difference and I see a
difference in traction of pollen and
ovulate cones and also a big dip in
attraction to pollen cones so I go back
to the plants and I take volatiles the
same way I told you but I do it every
hour for pollen cones and for ovulate
cones every hour and watch how those
volatiles change throughout the course
of the day the first thing I noticed is
that there is a characteristic pattern
in both in both pollen cones and ovulate
counts so pollen cones are in blue here
goblet cones are in red what you're
seeing is the percent composition of 1/3
octave that's all I'm looking at now not
even little ole which you know obviously
because it's the other compound does an
opposite shape what you see is that
there's a real dip in production of 1/3
octave diene in the middle of the day
and then they approach a hundred percent
so this is not this is not overall
amount that they produce this is what
they are producing they produce these
two compounds and they shift making only
1/3 octave diene towards the evening a
little after 8:00 p.m. and I can see
also that pollen cones on average
produce overall more volatile so this is
both 1/3 octave ena and little o how
much do they produce and I'm looking at
total ion abundance which is a value
that I get from GCMs pollen cones again
in blue so pollen cones produce more
than ovulate cones and they have some
peak at the end is that peak related to
1/3 octave a very similar graph but this
is now looking just at 1/3 octave e not
at overall volatiles and yes the pollen
cones produce more 1/3 octave diene and
have a big increase at the end of the
day in 1/3 octave e ok so at the same
time that I'm taking these volatile
measurements every hour I'm also
videotaping cones so I've got all these
pollen cones 10 of them that I've broken
off and put in these little plastic
containers
airflow in them and I videotape them all
day long and they just literally go and
count how many weevils are in you know
how many weevils are in the container
which means out of the cone and what I
see is that at this time that I have
this big increase percent increase in
production of 1/3 octave een in the
pollen cones that's the same time that I
have a big expulsion of pollinators from
the pollen counts so I'm counting and
it's like two two two two forty right so
there's some massive movement and I wish
that I'm just not technologically
advanced enough to be able to take like
a ten-hour video and break it down into
thirty seconds for you guys because it's
insanely striking I mean you're just
watching and there's nothing nothing
nothing nothing and then it's just a
million weevils right so we so our idea
here is that I'm going to break this
down and just use two one pollen count
and one ovulate cone to make it a little
bit clearer but our dia here is that
there is difference in concentration
that is attractive to the pollinator and
that the plants use their daily
patterning as a way to move the
pollinators between the pollen cone and
ovulate con so it's almost as if there's
this low level of production of 1/3
octave een and this looks like zero but
it's slightly above it's just not really
attractive to the pollinators they just
don't really care it's not enough to get
them to move or get them to do anything
but then there's a window that is
attractive to them an amount that they
like and an amount that they don't like
right and the way I always describe this
is my husband I love it if he has a
little aftershave on but I cannot stand
Cologne
so we've all been next to this person on
the elevator and you want to get off as
fast as you can alright that's the same
thing that the weevils are doing we
believe so
just schematically that would look a
little something like this there's a
pollen cone here on the left an ovule it
cone here on the right you have your
increase in production of 1/3 octave
Dean sort of as a heat map and you can
imagine that over that daily cycle
there's an amount that is attractive to
weevils they're happy and they hang out
in there then they get on the elevator
with mr. stinky and they've got to get
off and the only thing that works for
them because their entire life is bound
to this plant this plant
that smell is where they're gonna lay
their eggs it's where they're gonna feed
it's where they're gonna reproduce
they're gonna mate right they're gonna
their larvae are going to develop
so they have no desire to find anything
else and so once they're pushed out of
this cone they're sort of pulled into
this cone sort of deceptively right a
cheap mechanism because there's no food
here for them and then maybe and so in
this case this is still an unknown to me
is this one consistent amount or is
there sort of a it appears from this
data and it it appears that what's
happening is the female cone is making
not enough to be attractive but is
becoming attractive at the same time
that the pollen cone is becoming
repulsive right but from the earlier
data showing them in the lab it seemed
like maybe the female cone is being
pretty consistent throughout the day so
that I think we should work out a little
bit more but this is actually called
push-pull pollination and it's been
described and one other species of or
one of their genus one species period
but it's in a different genus macrosomia
and macadamia have pollinators that are
thrips vastly vastly different from
beetles right so we know that the same
pollination mechanism exists in
macadamia and ends amia and we also know
that that thermogenic patterning that I
told you about produces a similar
volatile patterning like we like I'm
showing so we know that it's not just
that an increase in temperature makes
you more stinky it's actually that the
substrates that are necessary for
volatile production are produced during
the thermogenic process and so it's it's
a you're able to test and see that it's
predictable that there's a pattern where
you have a peak and thermogenesis at
about ten to thirty minutes later you
have a peak in volatile production we
also know that everywhere that it's been
tested in cycads every time it's been
tested we have this volatile patterning
and of course we know that that
thermogenesis is ancestral in the group
so this really suggests to us that
because every cycad has brewed site
mutualists where the organisms live
within the pollen cone and that every
pollen cone undergoes this thermogenesis
that we know creates this volatile
patterning we think that this
pollination mechanism may be ancestral
in this group and in fact
maybe a pollination mechanism that
existed before the visual signaling that
you get with the rise of flowering
plants so just a brief summary of that
little section we know that they only
perceive 1/3 octave Dean and that it's
both a repellent and an attractant and
that plants change that amount
throughout the course of the day in a
predictable pattern and that that can
enact weevil movement between the pollen
cone and the ovulate column and this
push-pull pollination mechanism is
likely ancient and has existed long
before the rise of flowering plants
potentially but in still understanding
mechanisms I need to bring in this idea
of parasitism because these are these
pollinators are herbivores of the plants
and the plants are super toxic right so
in order to understand that one of the
first things I did was look at a
phylogeny of Lepidoptera so Lepidoptera
is the order that includes butterflies
and moths and this may come as a massive
surprise to you because it totally blew
my mind is coming from a plant
background butterflies are nested within
moths they're not two separate
monophyletic groups which is incredible
I expected gas so this black is
butterflies and all of the gray are
moths
I've colored on the tips here where we
have evolutions of sike had every in
many cases they are radiation so there
general that have radiated onto cycads
and have you know 8 to 20 species and in
most cases so all of these guys which
include butterflies and a couple Moss
these large herbivores that feed on
leaves there's a post Matic coloring it
may not be as obvious in this one but it
is we do not see any a plasmatic
coloring here no somatic just means that
they have warning coloration they're
like I'm super bright red don't eat me
because I'm toxic and we know a little
bit about this one here
that it does sequester the plant toxins
that it uses them in their own body for
defense against against herbivores these
guys down here are all detritivores
which means that they feed on dead
tissue and so it's possible that they're
feeding on dead cones we're back where
some of these chemical compounds these
toxins may have already been leached
from that system who knows what's going
on with these little guys but looking at
this gives me the idea that psych had
every has evolved many times
independently right
and what's more likely that they all got
the same ability to feed on toxic psyche
heads or that they acquired some ability
to feed on toxic psyche heads and so for
that in order to understand the
mechanisms I thought I would look at the
gut bacteria we know a lot about what
God bacteria does and how it's related
to diet and so I thought maybe these
guys all have shared shared gut bacteria
I guess these are my questions so is
their shared got bacteria amongst
herbivores of psyche had tissues and if
so can we infer anything from the
function so for this what I first did
was I took herbivores from this is in
three different species of zania in
three different locations in Florida and
then one species of psychist and
Singapore
I took leaf herbivores cone herbivores
and there's two different one this guy
only feeds on the microscope or Phil
this one only feeds in the cone peat
uncle and then this guy that feeds on
the stem the underground stem and it is
very basically asked what is the
bacterial community of these herbivores
and is there anything shared so for this
you do something 16s sequencing you
sequence all the bacteria in their guts
and identify them sort of like I TS like
an eye tag for bacteria and then I just
looked at it with a diversity analysis
and the first thing I see that stands
out is that bacterial communities are
generally distinct so this is any
individual of this species
it's got bacterial community is more
closely similar to other gut bacterial
communities of the same species this is
not surprising this is totally expected
and we expect we expect phylogeny to
have an influence on gut bacteria I can
also look at the core so that last image
was every bacteria in the gut so you
yourselves may have 200 species of
bacteria in your gut right but if I took
the gut bacterial community of everyone
in this room and everyone had 200
species and I asked what's the core what
are bacteria that are found in the guts
of all humans and maybe that there are
three species or ten species or 15
species that are found in every single
one of us and so that's what I did for
each one of these and the first thing
you see is that six species here and
then large ones for some of these
beetles also again not surprising we
know from the literature that
butterflies in general have
transient bacteria they don't have
really a core bacteria and beetles
usually do this is a little interesting
the other thing that's interesting to me
is that this guy these guys are feeding
on leaves and this guy is feeding on a
microscope Phil right so it's a little
more similar than some of the other
tissues right who's feeding on a stem
and a confit Dunkel but when I look at
all of those I find that there are five
shared bacteria amongst all of them
which is also super interesting when you
think that these guys only have six so
five of their six are found in all other
cycad herbivores and not in related non
cycad feeding out groups so can I infer
anything about this function and yes
just a few things use the bacteria we're
able to identify one two species one two
genus and then two two families and one
totally unidentified and we can get some
information about them we know that
these two both do nitrogen fixation we
know that Penta way I can be involved in
oxygen talks and degradation and protein
hydrolysis which is particularly
interesting because BMAA is a non
protein amino acid and what it does is
get into or one of the things that does
is get into your proteins and change the
conformation but we also have this
interesting anti-cancer capability and
in fact this is used it's this bacteria
is found in earthworms and is used in
Chinese medicine related to cancer and
it has I'm gonna have to read it so I
don't get it wrong
cytotoxicity and a Potok ik topic and
necrotic death of mammalian cancer cells
due to the activity of a protein
polysaccharide complex so that gives us
some interesting idea that maybe these
bacteria are involved with the ability
to feed on toxic cycads it was
interesting enough to us that we went
and did this even further so that
previous study was published but is
interesting enough that we did further
we have 12 species now of herbivores
from all across the world and this was
your idea for this figure it was great
it's beautiful so I hope you all
understand it but so you can see there
we have all different feeding tissues
and and across different generative
cycads and from different geographies
and those five shared bacteria are still
there I'm working with some colleagues
down at Long hibiyo they're working out
the function of these bacteria so
they have cultured insects gut bacteria
that I brought them from they have
cultured them in the presence and
absence of BMAA one of the toxins grown
them up over time they have been
separately individually cultured
bacteria and sequence their genomes and
we're working just this week even on on
that publication they're finding some
pretty interesting stuff understanding
the function that these bacteria may be
doing but I don't have time to get into
it today so maybe for further time so we
know that there is a core microbiome of
feeding on psyche head plants and then
it may allow in some way maybe maybe
it's just transient maybe this may be
the psych heads in the in this gut
bacteria is selecting for this and has
nothing to do with the insects right but
this was the first evidence of
convergence of a gut bacterial community
across a diverse set of insects that
share a common host plant so if we go
back to our questions that we're
interested in in relationships we can
ask them about psych heads and we can
think about what is the evolutionary
trajectory and so this is something that
I'm here working on with with Chelsea we
know a little bit about the evolutionary
history of psych heads and in fact
there's just this really amazing
phylogeny where the lineages themselves
are quite ancient but the general have
all recently radiated and and we have a
published phylogeny of zania the the
genus that I study just this last year
but we don't know anything about the
evolutionary history of anybody else
involved in this mutualism network we
don't have the evolutionary history of
the pollinators of the butterflies of
the bacteria and so looking at an
evolution of a mutualism network as a
whole and not as individual players and
understanding how those relationships
have evolved over time and how there may
be correlations that are what
correlations may exist that we've been
unaware of until now and then
understanding some of the morphology
that may be associated with these
relationships
what type of symbiosis are we so it
seems pretty obvious right that the
pollinators are mutualists they produce
they provide reproductive services to
the plant they're necessary the plants
don't set seed unless the pollinators
are there and they feed on essentially
disposable tissue just cone tissue that
is going to die and rot away after the
reproductive event anyways but like I
said there's all there's a little bit
parasitism and every
relationship which my husband doesn't
like when I say but oh my god it's so
true and if you guys don't have kids yet
it gets even worse but this is something
that I'm working on a little bit further
here with Rob Roy do so in the
neurobiology department I just really
want to understand from the plants
perspective you need your volatiles to
be to be static essentially you need to
be able to your pollinator has to be
able to find you and we've shown that
that's really important
volatile production is really important
to that however you also need to hide
from your herbivores because like I said
these herbivores decimate they can
decimate an adult plant right nothing
feeds on them because they're super
toxic and they aggregate in great
numbers need a plant to the ground so
there's strong selective pressure in
both both areas right sort of opposing
selective pressures but similarly you
have something going on with the insects
we know that these highly specialized
relationships are sort of tenuous right
those are people call them evolutionary
dead ends so you don't what do you do
what mechanisms exist that both maintain
fidelity the pollinator to the plant but
also allow for diversity that also allow
for you to change host plants or to find
host plants and that may explain
diversification in both of these
lineages and maybe even explain some of
this crazy phylogeny that we see what
mechanisms keep us together that's what
I really talked about today and I think
your therapist will tell you it's
communication and eius and by osis
biologists will tell you it's
communication you have to make sure that
your signal is clear are you telling
your partner what you mean to be telling
them you have to understand how they
perceive the signal are they even
capable of perceiving a signal and
showing up and being there at that
moment to understand what you're saying
what is their behavioral response right
to the signal that you're producing and
and doesn't give you the desired outcome
right does your communication give you
the desired outcome and of course there
may be some hidden diversity and this is
something we talk a lot about and even
something that Chelsey with her new Dean
position thinks a lot about there's
hidden diversity that allows us to show
up and be present in this moment and is
things that we don't know about and that
in biology have been less tractable
until now but maybe there is something
that is necessary before you can even
show up and be a part of this really
changeup and then of course has there
been any evolutionary innovation and I
think that the really wonderful thing
about systems like this some systems
that we would call a component community
is that meaning that it's something
where there's a psych head over E is a
unique and sort of unusual food source
and kind of extreme food source because
of its toxicity and unique and extreme
environments in nature we expect a lot
of endemics and that's what we have
cycad herbivores are almost exclusively
except for these weird to try divorce
but almost exclusively specialized on to
psych heads and feed on nothing else and
when you have a system like that allows
you to ask really wonderful questions
looking at convergence and weave and you
can see great examples in the literature
where people use convergence to
understand molecular mechanisms and
ecological mechanisms and we're having
some of the first evidence that there
may be some sort of I'm not even sure
what you would call this an ecological
convergence of interactions I'm not sure
but so because we have this great
component community of not just the
butterflies but also the the the Beatles
and the weevils we can ask questions
about what it means to be a cycad
herbivore and with that I'll just thank
everyone these are people that help
specifically with this work James was
actually just here a couple weeks ago
giving a talk he specifically helped me
with that behavioral arena and the
tracking he's responsible for that
amazing video not me and a lot of people
that help specifically with the work I
really need to thank Montgomery
Botanical Center this is the
conservation garden down in Florida if
any of you work on psych heads or palms
please go there they are highly
dedicated to conserving these plants but
also to research they are there for you
and they do incredible work I did all
this work as as a graduate student and
Noemi Pierce's lab and so you can see I
was in a butterfly lab but I studied
plants really she studies species
interactions and then I just want to end
by saying I'm on the board of the cycad
Society which we send out quarterly
newsletters related to psych head
research dedicated to conservation and
research and we even have some small
grants for psych head related research
and I brought some fliers for it if
anyone's interested in joining it's a
great society there's flyers in the back
and up here so please come
to me if you're interested and that's it
I take some questions if anyone has any
[Applause]
honor in the cycad leads no so we have
that some of the work we've done down at
Long hibiyo so they're specifically
looking even at the caller ID roots
right and we're not finding a
correlation of them being on the plant
tissue or even within the caller ID
roots so that so they're still ongoing
debate about if BMAA is produced by the
plants or the santa bacteria so santa
bacteria is the only other place in in
nature that you find BMA and in fact
that's why it's so connected to
Alzheimer's and ALS and that sort of
stuff I mean they find BMA in the brains
of these patients but there has been
work where they've grown the plants in
sterile conditions without the presence
of sound of bacteria and find that they
still produce BMAA and even that there's
sort of like a like sequester
sequestering I guess to use an insect
term of BMAA in certain tissues right
that would be more than the sound of
bacteria can produce so and dennis
Stevenson who's a good friend and on my
committee really strongly believes that
there's been this horizontal gene
transfer from that and so of course I
love him so I sort of believe it but I
but I don't know I mean and you can
probably attest the difficulty it would
be to grow something without
cyanobacteria getting into it right so
that's kind of a problem with thinking
about that that work but I don't know so
that the reason that we chose BMAA
in at long hibiyo to grow the bacteria
in the presence and absence of BMAA is
because we thought that BMAA would have
more effect on bacteria than the mam
glycosides right and we are finding
interesting stuff right so the idea of
growing bacteria in the presence and
absence is saying how do i watch this
community of bacteria change over time
and with with BMAA in the system are
they using BMAA do we see BMAA change
its concentration change in the system
and we do so understanding how exactly
BMAA may have something to do with
bacteria is interesting
but I don't have the answer for you yet
and of course you know there's
potentially great medical implications
for this right because of the connection
with Alzheimer's and and whatnot but I
don't have the answer for exactly what
it might be doing yeah yeah sorry
species where his face has to take down
there else does it look like when we are
dying is a consistent signal and so
within my species
absolutely it's in every one I've ever
tested and we have I've tested quite a
bit across Zambia and that's one of the
things I'm doing here with Chelsea is
looking at other phenotypes as well as
the volatile phenotypes across the
phylogeny and it is not common in in
Zambia it is found in one other it's
found in two other species of
encephalitis which are like super
million years diverged in Africa but in
fact one of the things I didn't have a
chance to talk about is I've gone
further because I'm going in this idea
of coevolution and so here's the one
that I showed you I'm just gonna call it
the blue species 1/3 octave een and I
I've done now another species because
this you have to use live weevils for
this to cut their heads off and stuff
and so since there's only two that I can
do that with right and so in this one
this plant produces vastly different
chemical compounds and the weevil
responds to this is methyl salicylate
actually and they cannot perceive the
other host plant so this weevil cannot
perceive 1/3 docketing and this weevil
cannot perceive methyl salicylate so it
is not common within zania 1/3 arcanine
but it is common within the larger or
not even common but does exist within
the larger group of psyche heads so
might come out incorrectly it seems to
me that there's producers produced and
what this was the Coons and at this
point is the amount of
then produced by the Millikan's is it
they just mooing out because there isn't
that much in producing something else
that attracts the Beavers yeah so I
think that that kind of gets it two
questions one is is insect tracking and
insect signaling right and so when
you're an insect can you have to travel
a long distance your first connection is
volatile right that's the thing that
tracks you from a long distance until
closer and that's usually when visual
signaling kicks in and then of course
you land and there's tactile simulating
and gustatory receptors on the little
legs and stuff once they get in and
remember because these are dioecious
plants these and they're you should see
them they're like these big bushes right
so the weevils have to get out of that
and I think they're sort of pushed out
of that because of that smell and then
how they find the other one it they're
likely still looking for the same smell
that maybe at a lower signal but the
cones their only other tracking would be
sort of a visual signaling to get to the
female cones from that perspective so
that's one of the reasons I want to work
with Robert do so is to think about
things we know that there's
thermogenesis involved which means that
there's humidity and there's you know
even like thermal thermal signaling
right that's involved that we would like
to look at it's possible that the pollen
that the ovulate cones are acting as an
attractant at that lower level right or
it's possible that it's just completely
by mistake and that that the pollen
cones active is an attractant at a lower
level and a repellant at a higher level
and it's really all about men but I'm
like so sick of living in a world where
it's all about men but I really want to
believe that the woman's making a choice
right but I do but I don't know I don't
have that I don't have that that data to
show right I have done like sticky traps
near pollen cones and or ovulate cones
and then sticky traps just sort of like
in the world right and the ovulate cones
do get more insects on the sticky traps
then the ones that are out in the world
but it's also chaotic you saw how many
hundreds of insects are on a pollen cone
all of a sudden it's just like a burst
of weebles that are out and flying
around it could totally be by accident
but in nature like that picture I showed
in Panama some of these like you're not
showing up and sing like a bunch of
cycads really close to each other it's
they have to travel quite a ways right
so how are they right that I don't know
but it is true that in all psyche heads
that the females have a lower level of
that in all cycads we know that the the
patterning is the same and it's at the
same time and that females produce less
heat and less volatiles even even if
you're like correcting first size and
stuff like is that not well so if you
think about you're an insect right your
warrant your cold-blooded right so any
heat is gonna allow you to just warm up
your fly muscles which is going to make
you more active so it's the same as like
a chemical chemical process that you
would do in organic chemistry with heat
things just start like bumping around
and moving around more so I believe
unquestionably thermogenesis has some
cue for the insects what's interesting
is that you can in it you can elicit
this behavior in both the thrips that
were studied before and the weevils that
i've studied here regardless of
temperature and we also know that the
temperature if you recall I showed that
there's a temperature increase it's
about thirty minutes before the volatile
increase that we don't see them behavior
really starting to happen and tell that
thirty minutes which of course like is a
little window of time honestly right so
a massive window of time but so I think
that unquestionably thermogenesis has
something to do with it
just because the weevils will become
more active and they'll be more able to
fly and more because these guys don't
like they don't fly really and they even
play dead when you're working on them
they're sort of like I mean really it's
kind of adorable and they lay there for
a while before they get up so
temperature there's no way that you
could have such a strong signal as a
plant and have it not have some some
impact but the fact that you can create
this behavior based just on that
and like I said temperature also affects
humidity which affects all kinds of
stuff right so that's a lot what I want
to work out is like what are all of the
signals she's around this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu